all right so after having a total and
utter failure to get this to work on my
laptop I'm gonna have to do it from my
phone which takes me off more than a
little bit ah people yes ah I'm really
sorry that a that this started late and
B that I'm doing it for my phone in this
weird awkward manner because technology
hates me
this thing this is a big part of why I'm
really nervous when it comes like to the
point I cuz I'm almost there where I'm
gonna be able to like upgrade my camera
and whatnot I just have the worst luck
cuz whenever stuff goes wrong for me it
always goes wrong in a way that it's
never supposed to go wrong it's so like
I can't get help for it so I'm gonna do
my best to keep up with the chat it
Scrolls by really quick know what I'm
doing it from the phone so let's say um
[Music]
yeah I just I gotta go with that
okay so this is how it's gonna be I will
try not to miss you know things that
people say or ask questions or whatever
oh okay
that's a good one to start out with
pronouns short answer is they are
situational so for the purposes of this
channel I generally tell people go with
masculine pronouns because that's
generally how I present here but it
basically you gotta kind of cue off how
I'm presenting which is why I don't get
hung up on pronouns really so whatever
is like the one that comes to your head
when you think of me just go with that
I'm not gonna be offended will you be
doing an Avengers 4 trailer review has
that come out did I miss the fact I'm
sorry I've had a crazy weekend so it yes
when it's out I will talk about it if
it's out now then yeah I have to catch
up for that um let's see Coke or Pepsi
neither
I don't like soda what has happened to
your
hands nothing it's not cast it's it's
hand warmers because the heat in my room
kinda stinks a best episode of this
series of Doctor Who so far I think it's
ker-blam for me it's between that and
demons of the pudding job are you
excited for Christmas I am not nearly as
excited as my daughter is am I gonna see
Aquaman yes I don't have particularly
high expectations for it but I hope it's
good
did you do where did I get this shirt
Amazon a number of people have asked
about where I picked up my my 13th
Doctor outfit that I've been wearing for
the reviews I picked it up on Amazon
like two months ago so I was sure to get
this before I knew it was gonna become
scarce cuz the the series had started
do you collect Funko pops I actually
don't because I don't like the faces I
don't like the thing that Funko pops do
with the eyes it's weird to me like I
don't mind it when it's on a creature
but when it's on a human I like I just
don't like that aesthetic so yeah Funko
pops not not my bag I got a scroll back
am i excited for the new Lion King know
anyone who see my rant about Disney
remaking it's it's old stuff yeah die I
will never be excited for a Disney
live-action remake and I probably won't
see it either
man haha I'm gonna miss some of these
questions I'm gonna try and get to them
I'm trying to back up here why there's
so many toxic Doctor Who reviewers on
you I don't know I try very hard not to
live in that world so I don't even
really want to speculate favorite pizza
depends on my mood honestly I really
like Hawaiian some people think that
pineapple on pizzas blasphemy I don't
think would you like just we need to
write for Doctor Who know cuz Joss
Whedon has a very Joss Whedon style and
I don't I don't love the idea of him
sort of coming into something that has
its own feel and style cuz I don't
necessarily want him to be projected
onto it like when it's a comic book
issue or whatnot that's one thing but
something like tie to now I wouldn't
really I wouldn't really care for that
even though I do like Java Sweden stuff
by and large predictions for the season
11 finale don't really have any
um I do still think brains gonna die I
mean I've called that since early on
thoughts thoughts on salt and vinegar
crisps not my thing
I don't actually eat crisps in the US
and beat potato chips very often they're
kind of an occasional for me did you
ever read DC's Flintstones comic I
didn't but I did hear about that I heard
fascinating things about that and if I
was keeping up with current comics I
might that would be something for me to
get around to but yeah not so much if
you had to pitch a Cyberman story what
would the plot be I don't know like that
like I have some ideas for Dalek stories
that I've talked about that before but
Cybermen I don't know man I don't think
I have any notions that's better than
anything else that's already been done
I'm not going to address the rumors of
chip nose and Whitaker leaving cuz as
long as they are rumors I don't want to
talk about them I try to stay off the
room rumor mill my daughter is seven
this year are you gonna start a gaming
channel channel no absolutely not that's
not a I'm not a current gen gamer
like I most up-to-date thing I have is a
ps3 and like I'm having to stream this
from my phone because technology hates
me so the idea of trying to get that to
work and something that I don't think
too many people care about my opinion on
because most gamers would consider me
did not be a gamer anymore
ya know that's not that's not something
I gonna dip my toes into my daughter's
name I'm not gonna answer that just
because out of respect for her privacy
when she gets to an age where I feel
like she understands enough about what
being online means um I'd be more open
to that but I you know at seven I don't
think she knows the possible
implications of her name and her face
being associated with my stuff so I'm
not gonna share that although she has a
cool name I'll go with the hell I'll let
you know that what actor would you
choose for the next doctor I don't know
I need to do a video down the line on
when I think they should go back to a
male doctor or whether they should stick
with a female 4i because I'm really of
two minds of the whole thing because
there's the there's the general feeling
of who should be next but then there's
like the meta issues of what it means to
either keep it as a woman or to go back
to a man and
yeah I got a do I got a devote a whole
video to that witch doctor do you think
has the best look at forth but between
the Hat and the scarf it's just it's
just too iconic
would you like Rosa without the ending
or a different ending I don't know I
still have very mixed and complicated
feelings about Rosa I don't I've sort of
eased off my position before that maybe
it was a story they shouldn't have told
because I've taken enough enjoyment out
of the sort of conversation that's
happened around the episode I think a
lot of that conversation was stuff worth
having and worth talking about I still
just have very mixed feelings on it
overall favorite campaigns of series
eleventh so far it's Graham that's an
easy call favourite Russell T Davies
series ad series four I mean that's
still my favorite series of the show
have I ever played portal I haven't I I
would love to but no I haven't my
favorite doctor honestly it depends on
what day you ask me like currently it's
it's Tom Baker but like it it can and
has and will change like this stuff
moves around Mary Poppins returns I mean
I just don't care that much Mary Poppins
returns doesn't aggravate me the way
that you know the Lion King and stuff
like that aggravating
like there were actually book sequels so
you know I can't really begrudge them
that too much are you going to get those
limited edition Doctor Who classic
Doctor Who blu-rays probably not I don't
buy physical media very much anymore I
don't buy digital either to be honest
generally you know what I can't get
streaming it if there's something that I
want to be sure that I have like forever
I will get a physical copy um but I'm
not into like collector's editions I
just want to know that I have it so that
it cannot be yanked away from me which
digital media can favorite number of the
alphabet and why is it orange well no
you're wrong sir my favorite number of
the alphabet is bliing so you're gonna
have to try again no nail varnish today
I wanted to get my nails done I hadn't
had time like I've been running around
this entire weekend I went with my
daughter and her mother to Santa's
Village which is a theme park over in
New Hampshire
did that yesterday and last night it was
with I you know I was seeing Liz my
partner and today I went to go visit a
friend and then I had to rush back for
this and as soon as this is done I got
to go to a rehearsal so like I have not
had time to like sit down this whole
weekend let's see yeah some people like
Funko pops but yeah they're just not my
thing
do you feel that DC as a company gets
too much hatred compared to Marvel I
it's hard for me to say because I'm not
as I'm not as plugged into like the
comics fandom as as some other fandoms
that said most of the friends that I
have who are really into comics are more
into DC and most of them are really
ticked off at DC so at least from where
I sit and the people I know who are
giving DC a lot of hate it's people who
want to love it so you know it's it's
it's hard to say I I think here's what
I'll say I think DC as a company might
get too much hate I think Warner
Brothers as the studio and the greater
company that owns DC uh is getting
everything it deserves cuz I have little
to no respect for them and how this
thing keeps growing down from the to the
bottom ah let's see
I am absolutely gonna miss some of these
our bowtie school of course they're cool
how are you today I'm pretty good
thoughts on Titus and Ramadan
oh I've only finished the first series
of kimmy schmitt I have been meaning to
get back to it I just keep there's so
many things that I'm trying to catch up
on that crazy ex-girlfriend and and a
whole bunch of other stuff yeah I've
just started watching sense8 so like I
keep jumping around the best comic-con
near VT well Vermont comic-con has been
good in previous years I wasn't able to
go this year and I heard mixed things
about what happened this year they
changed venues and change cities where
it was I have never been to Granite Con
which is in New Hampshire but her good
things about that I've been to Boston
Comic Con which is nice but it's big so
that one's that can be a little
overwhelming
are you into tabletop RPGs like D&D at
all I am I'm actually part of a gaming
group right now
doing a cyberpunk well the RDM is
calling it cyberpunk
21:20 cuz cyberpunk 2020 is a pretty
dated system but like I'm not deep into
it but I enjoy it when I get the chance
should dr. who do love crabbed at some
point not I don't think Doctor Who
should ever like incorporate Lovecraft
as a character or like flat-out ever
save the name Cthulhu I kind of would
like Doctor Who to deal in Cthulhu esque
and love crafty and stuff which honestly
I kind of consider the beast and
impossible planet the Satan pit to be
kind of Lovecraftian cuz like it is
implied like this is kind of the devil
but there's a whole lot of we're really
not entirely sure what that was and
that's one things I really like about
that I will kind of like that to get in
there a little bit views on remakes of
cult classics such as Flash Gordon or
labyrinth I think it that's a tough call
because oftentimes cult classics have
fundamental flaws in them and I on
principle I'm not against remaking
something that didn't quite work but
then oftentimes cult classics are called
classes because they're lightning in the
bottle and there was something about
them that you can't actually replicate
so it's kind of a minefield and it's
hard to say especially given how cynical
most remakes are my inclination would be
to say just don't cuz usually cult
classics or something built on a passion
remakes aren't as a rule so it just kind
of clashes does your daughter play games
if so if so what games does she like I'm
assuming you mean video games by that
question she games a little I'm like she
and I burned through pretty much all of
rayman legends over the course of the
last few months she really enjoyed that
it's tough for me because there aren't I
don't have as many
cooperative two-player games as I would
like and that's kind of her and that's
my preferred way to play with her is to
play co-op as opposed to competitive so
like I've got things like you know older
Smash Brothers and Mario Kart games but
I don't want to play those with her
because I don't want to play against her
I want to play with her have you seen
James Bond I have I have not seen every
James Bond I really hated Spectre like I
hated Spectre a lot so I'm not I'm not
in a good mood on the James Bond
Chai's right now have you ever read any
doctor who books short stories or any
other written stories I haven't like
I've only just started to dip into the
other media with the the Big Finish and
whatnot but I have still don't make the
comics or the novels that I'm like the
novels it's really unlikely I have so
little time to get through books anymore
so yeah have you ever talked to mr.
TARDIS not in person like we tagged each
other and stuff but that's that's been
the extent of it
you seem British to me he don't know why
I keep forgetting you're American I'll
take that as a as a compliment I think
it probably helps that like for an
American I have a kind of neutral accent
I have kind of a New England dish but
not particularly strong accent like I
don't have a Vermont accent like the
closest I have is I use Yelp instead of
yes sometimes that's about the extent of
it a MOSFET or chip no I'm not gonna
make that call because there's too much
background on Moffatt like I know
exactly how Moffitt's entire thing went
Chibnall I know how the first series has
gone but that lie I'm gonna do my
summation on what I think Chibnall has
done and how he's handling things at a
later date do you eat meat yes so I'm
not a vegetarian I'm not a vegan I have
plenty of friends who are but I'm not
that said I'm not like your meat is just
you know I eat meat okay what a series
long story such as children of Earth
America miracle day work for Doctor Who
in might but I've never really wanted to
see Doctor Who go that way and then that
kind of continuing serialized
storytelling I mean it could it could
even work I just I don't know
have you watched any more of inside
number nine no I haven't not yet I would
like to get around to it but I again I
haven't had that it's hard for me to
find time to watch things that I'm not
also gonna get a video out of because I
mean keep in mind I have a full-time job
and something vaguely resembling a life
so you know there's there's a lot going
on
did you hear Daredevils guess I did
video on that next
our favorite Disney movie Oh God
my nostalgia cancer is the Little
Mermaid but as an as an adult I
recognize a lot of issues with that
movie so yeah I don't know I don't know
what it would be these days it might
honestly be Zootopia
have you seen code geese I don't know
what that is um question are you a
Gundam fan no I've never seen Gundam my
my experience in anime is usually more
in the movies not nearly as much in the
series favorite Doctor Who collectible
it's it's the sonic screwdrivers I
always loved the sonic screwdrivers what
do I do for a living I work in sales I'm
not going to get more specific than that
but yeah I just
and it's like physical sales I'm not
like selling insurance I sell a physical
product and not to individuals to stores
that stock up and carry it on shelves
and things like that yes so Doctor Who
is starting soon so for those of you in
the UK and Doctor Who is about to start
if you want to buy a bow out at this
time if I suddenly have a big drop of
the number of people logged in no hard
feelings I get it
like I I really wanted to do this
yesterday but it just things went crazy
and I couldn't make it work I'm missing
moth that are you I don't I don't know
like I said I'm gonna when I talk about
Chibnall overall I might touch on that
[Music]
what's the performance you're rehearsing
for I have a burlesque show
not I have a brushing through no two
weeks so two weekends from now I am
doing a number for a burlesque show that
is a tribute to Queen everyone's picking
a queen song that that they're
performing a number two so I'll be in
that um favorite Neil Breen film I'm not
sure who Neil Breen is so I couldn't say
favorite superhero spider-man it that
will probably always be my answer you
should play half-life 2 I'm sure I'm
sure I should I have it is it wrong that
I can only imagine you as a torso like I
wouldn't be surprised if you didn't have
well I do I do have legs but yeah no
fair enough
have you ever been to Disneyland in
California Adventure I haven't I've been
to Disney World in Florida
several times I've never been to
Disneyland
have you watched Seinfeld not writ like
that was one of the shows my grandfather
would watch and I used to spend summers
with my grandparents so that was one of
those things that kind of absorbed
vicariously but not so much something I
actively will watched weirdest Nursery
Rhyme ever I rock-a-bye baby
what does that baby doing in the tree
how would you like people to approach
the topic of your burlesque performance
without being creepy I just ask if you
have questions about the burlesque end
of things just ask could trust me I've
fielded really weird questions over the
years oh thank you
did Pete we just send it saying nice
words and I appreciate it I appreciate
it
you think DC Comics Dark Knight's metal
would be an epic event to adapt for an
anime movie I haven't read it so I
couldn't say I in general I I wish the
animated films were doing more original
stories as opposed to adaptations that
said Death of Superman was really good
but by and large I like the MA films
better when they're doing their own
thing favorite Disney Princess character
ah I kind of leaned towards Moana on
that just because I loved the resolution
of that movie so much favorite villain
in Doctor Who ever oh god I don't know
for a recurring it might at this point
might be the Mond ask Ian Cybermen for a
one-off probably the empty child even
though ultimately you know it's more of
an obstacle than a like malicious
villain but it's still functionable oh
that story will you be streaming during
the episode will you stream your
reaction I won't remember I'm in the
u.s. so it's not airing here the same
time it's airing on in the UK what do I
think of furries I have no real thoughts
on furries I don't I I know a couple of
furries they're nice people yeah that's
not my world so you know
any tips on some good DC comics for a
teenager who's read The Killing Joke
here one death in the family
70% of nightfall mad love and a Deadpool
comic Wow um if that's if that's the
kind of comics they're into I'm not sure
I do because they've kind of read the
best of that darker end of things of
comics and to sort of stay into the the
darker edge Lordi kind of end of comics
it's only gonna get worse from there so
I kind of recommend see if you can get
them to embrace something a little more
light I mean dead and I suppose Deadpool
Deadpool could be a stepping stone to
some more irreverent stuff if they're
willing to step outside of superheroes
maybe give trans Metropolitan a try I
think that could really appeal to a
teenager could you make a video against
addressing a suit and danganronpa
character okay I've had this come up
before I don't know danganronpa at all
so like the amount of research I would
have to do to feel like I could speak on
that I'm I just don't think any of the
time favorite Pixar movie probably still
Toy Story 2 yeah I mmm yeah I think so
will you do reviews for muffets future
shows I mean I'm curious about how is
Dracula is gonna turn out so there's a
there's a distinct possibility I'll
address that when it when it gets around
to it this your first live stream yes it
is can you tell I'm sure you can
thoughts on Titan's I haven't watched it
greetings from Mexico hello there
top three musicals either perform
yourself or watch live at Broadway i I'm
I'm guessing you're asking for like for
a wishlist as opposed to stuff I've
actually done there aren't too many more
musicals that like I want to see I want
to both see perform live and be in next
to normal like really badly I also
really desperately want to be in Rocky
Horror Show at some point there isn't
too much else that like I really want to
see on Broadway I've seen most of the
stuff I really wanted to see like I've
seen Avenue Q and I've seen wicked and
I've seen The Lion King and they're all
they're great did you ever think you'd
get to this 30k milestone depending on
when you'd asked me no I if you'd asked
me like a
like a year and a half ago I would have
said no that's never going to happen
things were really started to pick up
back in 2017 in a way that I didn't
think would so yeah this is kind of
crazy
have you seen Disney's the wild and if
so would you think of it I've seen bits
and pieces I like Eddie Izzard I don't
really care for how realistic the rest
of it works I don't think it works very
well
broadchurch series 2 & 3 unlikely i I
did I didn't dislike broadchurch but I
didn't like it enough to be like yeah I
want to see more of these people being
depressed
do you watch attack on Titan I did three
episodes of attack on Titan it just
didn't grab me so I didn't keep with it
have you read Adventures of the super
Suns I haven't but I have a number of
friends who swear by that comic so I've
heard great things about it thoughts on
CBBC especially Sarah Jane Adventures
Sarah Jane Adventures I don't know if
it's something I'll ever talk about
because I
I liked them fine but because they're
aimed at a much younger age than I am I
just I did I never loved it and I don't
want to revisit it which I would have to
if I'm going to talk about it what are
you getting your daughter for Christmas
I'm not telling you that on the off
chance that any of this leaks out random
one favorite Netflix show I suppose I
can say black Mara now cuz that that's
now on Netflix so we'll go with that
some of these are repeat questions so
forgive me for not answering ones that I
did earlier opinions on a third season
at the good place so far it's doing
quite well I was actually really nervous
I'm like are they gonna be able to
sustain this and yeah it's going great
everything about Doctor Who it appeals
to the nine-year-old in me because like
it's basic premise is a person with a
magic box who can go anywhere that's
that just speaks my inner child have you
ever heard the dark have you ever heard
the doctor who knocked off the stranger
I have not well what's your word habit
procrastination
did that
see um what do you think of the talk to
sweat of YouTube draw a drama mob post
truth heckling spreading on YouTube it's
just something I try and stay out of
like somebody did a video earlier in the
week that you know kind of called me out
specifically and I'm like I'm addressing
that I'm aware it exists I haven't
watched all of it I'm not going to I
don't encourage people to seek it out
and I'm not gonna say who it was cuz I
don't want a dogpile some other person's
channel with my people who are there to
defend me I just don't want to be
dragged into that world at all a
favorite title sequence for Doctor Who
that is a tough call I am gonna be
ranking the title sequences at some
point down the line I really do like the
new one for series 11 honestly like a
lot what shows start a great but had the
biggest drop in quality uh for me right
now honestly it might be Jessica Jones
that first season was so great and then
the second season and I didn't really
like second season of strange of things
either though I seem to be in the
minority on that one thoughts on star
wars 9 I don't have any because we don't
really have any new information to go
off of opinions on Pertwee's TARDIS I
mean most classic TARDIS is it didn't
change much throughout that entire sort
of timeframe and they're fine did you
let's see
thoughts if any are critically acclaimed
shows such as gravity falls TV universe
duck tales 2017 Adventure Time the only
one of those that I've seen much of
anything of is the new duck tales which
I love the others I am aware of i but
again have not had time a help enter and
no look the existing hell-bent rant
exists you can find it it's not going
anywhere but I will drain myself if I
try and recreate that live has fanned
I'm always bitten this toxic or did the
oven of the internet just flush out the
trolls and cowards and that love to
shout out yes
fandom has actually always been this
toxic I'm old enough to feel comfortable
saying that it's just an issue of the
toxic people are can now find each other
and amplify their voice much more
whereas before or
you know things like the Internet it was
you know one guy out of ten and a fandom
was the Toxic one but now they can kind
of consolidate and just shout in one
voice but they've always been around
none of this is new did you see your
expression and the salt um nail is
unsettling yeah look first live stream
gimme a break did you cheat
do you have an advent calendar um well I
don't really my daughter has because
she's the one who does them so she has
one here and one other at her mother's
house
you said you watch legends of tomorrow
what do you think of this season I
hadn't see I haven't gotten to this
season yet because usually the way I
watch legends of tomorrow is I watch it
during the summer when most other stuff
is off the air because that's when it
goes on Netflix Horrible Histories I
have not seen do you want to have more
kids nope
I love my daughter but I I don't have it
in me to do it again she's awesome and
if I roll the dice the second time I'm
not gonna get that lucky again
game consoles do you have ps3 PS to ps1
and sixty-four GameCube SNES NES I think
that's it Game Boy Game Boy Advance game
boy das beste Avenger oh that's a tough
call I'm partial to say cap he's not my
favorite character but man he's awesome
favorite TARDIS and or sonic tart and
favorite TARDIS interior is 8th doctor
favorite sonic I think it's probably
still 11s pet peeves about anything ok
this is gonna sound targeted I don't
mean it to be people who shortened my
name I I go by Nathaniel I don't go by
Nate Nathan not none of that like
Nathaniel it's 3 syllables and it's a
pain in the butt and I know that but
that's that's my name does your daughter
watch Doctor Who she does not um she
does she knows what Doctor Who is and
she can recognize the TARDIS and she
knows all that but I haven't been able
to get her I haven't been able to get
her into most of my fandoms actually
thoughts on the movie Tomorrowland I
haven't seen it
let's go pokemons on the switch has a
co-op mode I don't have a switch so
there you go what do you think about
Captain Jack Harkness I I find him
fascinating as an artifact especially
people going you know that was the way
to do it cuz I again I'm old enough to
remember that people used to complain
that he was the first sign of the
homosexual agenda being forced into the
show and now the same people who claim
that about characters like Bill or the
way the show is going now
cite him is the way to do it right which
is really weird to me
do you eat corn on the cob around the
world or typewriters style III type
write it when I'm eating corn on the cob
what do you think about the episode turn
left turn left I like but I like it less
than a lot of people I'll get to detail
that more when I get around to it
eventually during overdue Doctor Who
reviews I've seen Jody's New Year's
scarf I did um is she trying too hard to
be the other doctors I don't think so
cuz I think that comes down to
performance I think it's an odd and it's
not dissimilar to when they just sort of
busted out
Osgood to be you know the the on-site
fangirl Skyfall was much better film
inspector yes it was
have you watched chilling Adventures of
Sabrina I haven't my partner Liz has my
mother has and they both had mixed
enough feelings that I'm not sure I care
too but we'll say did you you too see
that's kind of got asked already do you
think series 11 is getting why do you
think series 11 is getting so much hate
I really don't want to speculate on that
because I think that just feeds the
drama and like sort of emphasizes a
dividing line between fandoms between
those who like in those who don't and I
don't want to feed that so I don't
really want to I don't want to project
why I think other people don't like it
because that honestly that's just a road
for infighting a best character in the
office u.s. are you okay I don't like
the office I know that's like blasphemy
I don't like embarrassment humor I don't
enjoy cringe humor and that's kind of
what the show is did you thoughts on
budget course men as show that I really
want to watch cuz I've heard it's
amazing but I've also heard it's really
depressing and I'm not in a place where
I am up for being that depressed so do
you know anything about Briggs it I know
a bit
but I'm not gonna weigh in on that cuz
you know not my country not my circus
not my monkeys
moffat er Davies is the real question ah
boy I see I can make an argument in
either case I think ultimately that just
comes down to what you like because they
did different things very deliberately
so I think that's a preferential
question opinion on the game Awards
don't watch them who's better love
interest for the doctor Rosa River
nobody the doctor shouldn't have a love
interest there I said it
are you gonna watch review Marvel's
runaways I had planned to but at this
point for how long is gonna take me to
get around to it's probably not gonna be
topical anymore so I don't know I'm
watching American Horror Story please
send help depending on what season
you're watching yes you might need help
did you favorite master stories of the
well I mean if we're including Big
Finish it's the war master if we're
sticking to the show probably the Sea
Devils did you that gotta ass did a
favorite and least favorite thing about
chicken'll series 11 I don't want to
make that call yet until it's over
are you into anime is if yes and I mean
I am but like I said before I prefer
anime films the anime series so like for
anime films favorite is summer Wars I
love ghost in the shell I love Miyazaki
obviously so you know that kind of stuff
number of people asking about the jobs
still even mails out that interesting to
talk talk about I mean you know relative
to geeky stuff and the kinds of things I
talk about it gets comparatively boring
for this you heard that you'll go in
spoiler territory for TV movies do you
like or hate spoilers
III and avoid them before I see
something which is why I try very hard
to give very clear dividing lines when
I'm giving my thoughts on something on
when I'm gonna start to talk spoilers so
that people have the opportunity to opt
out I don't I mean like I only did it
when people drop spoilers without giving
a warning about that reddit using a mime
on reddit under viewer wild I'm not on
reddit under counsel of geeks um which
it's the same on Instagram as well
Twitter I'm on under both
Dark Phoenix pushed back again to June
2019 yeah that's not news that happened
about a month ago
have you watched my hero academia I
haven't like the extent that I know
about my hero academia I hosted a
burlesque show a nerd a nerd lesk show a
geek themed burlesque show where the
co-host dressed as one of the characters
from my hero academia that's about as
much as I know about it you're watching
dr. Lenny means I'm not it's not airing
where I am in eight minutes
didja to that's another question about
the toxic stuff if you could change a
doctor in an episode what would you
change like putting Capaldi and Rosa oh
boy that's an interesting question like
I'd have to think on that one I don't
know off the top my head um what do you
think of Lyndsey Ellis I like I like her
work I think she does really thoughtful
analysis of stuff I like her approach I
think she's thorough I don't always
agree with her but I like her
presentation let's see
yep people saying Doctor Who gotta go
god I'm so far behind like I'm dealing
with questions from like 60 minutes ago
best Queen song fat bottomed girls yes I
know some people can find the song
problematic I just love it which Queen
song am i performing to I'm performing
to who wants to live forever do you have
any tips for DC Comics to read I mean if
you're asking for current series I don't
cuz I'm not reading them currently
favorite DC hero Oh Shh favorite DC hero
prom I means it's probably Batman but
some of the worst stuff DC has ever
pointed out has been Batman so it can go
either way
opinion on a Doctor Who spin-off
featuring Paul McGann as the Eighth
Doctor I'm if there was a time to do it
it's not now like what I think might
have been cool is if prior to now they
had like started having the holiday
specials be McGann stories
but I wouldn't do it now because with
the what the fandom is splitted as it is
over the current series I wouldn't want
to create a situation where a chunk of
the fandom basically gets to go this is
Doctor Who that other thing isn't yeah I
don't think that's in anybody's best
interest let's see
do you like the green death I actually
haven't gotten to that one yet hoo boy
I I gotta I gotta try and catch up so
again if I miss people's favorite thing
on your knick-knack shelf I don't know I
love I love too much of my most missed
that means probably bun-bun because I
think I've had him the longest of
anything that's out there aside from the
gaming consoles favorite Lord of the
Rings movie Fellowship of the Ring a
favorite animated TV show of all time
the max the MTV miniseries message
retracted a favorite character on Gotham
I'm not going to talk about that one cuz
that's because after season 5 ends Liz
and I are gonna do top tens for Gotham
characters and that's gonna be a lot of
fun
how old is your YouTube channel and you
YouTube channel this one's been around
since 2012
I'm the 36 if you were to write a sci-fi
script what would you write about and
what pitfall would you want to avoid I
don't know cuz I've written sci-fi stuff
but it's generally been short story
stuff I don't know if I have a script in
me message retracted do you think yaz is
pointless and should be the first leave
of Harrison I don't think he's pointless
I think generally they find the least to
do with her are you a fan of any old
anime excluding classics that everybody
loves um it is hard for me to to say
because like I said I don't watch a lot
of the old especially the shows like
I've seen bits and pieces of things like
Sailor Moon and one I think probably the
oldest anime that I like again it's a
film it's not a show is the original
vampire hunter D but I do like the newer
one I do like bloodlust better it's
uhh Doctor Who on now good luck with the
rest of the livestream I'm trying to
back up cuz I ended up accidentally
skipping ahead in the chat and how uh
I'm so many questions are gonna get
missed I am so sorry guys have you ever
read Stephen King believe it or not I
haven't I tried like I like his ideas
his writing style doesn't grab me
opinion on Power Rangers don't really
have one I was a little too old when
that was on the air I was aware of it
sure doctors who would like to meet in a
multi doctor story ah boy like if it's
limited to who's actually still around
it's hard to say it like I had like my
fantasy pairing would be the 11th of
this and the second logistically what we
could actually do um I kind of like to
see the 8th and the and 12th what
character if you could erase out of
existence would beat Damian Wayne Damian
Wayne socks
what do you think about the pg-13
Deadpool it's fine I don't really have
thoughts on it the trailer was really
clever thoughts on the dark eyes look
for the Eighth Doctor do you think it's
can I don't know enough about that to
have an opinion um what do you think the
best villain of season 11 is I'm not
sure cuz I think if we're being honest
villains even when the episodes I've
liked villains have been the weak spot
for this show like I liked the guy
running the the contest in in the ghost
monument I don't know how much you count
him as a as a villain if you hear of any
Firefly serenity happenings will you let
us know well sure cuz I like that show
but I don't think anything's ever gonna
happen with that
have you watched Casanova by Russell T
Davies I have actually liked that quite
a bit that's a lot of fun um let's see
have you played the Ace Attorney games I
have not I I am aware of them I'm
actually fairly knowledgeable about
what's going on with gaming I'm just not
current with it
bunch of people saying by is they go to
watch Doctor Who
some do you think you could get 200k
subs maybe I think the issue is whether
or not YouTube completely implodes or
rearranges its algorithms or one if
things stay the way that they are sure
maybe in two years or so but like I
don't know
have you seen Supernatural I actually
haven't a hammer I'm a bad gig Scott
Pilgrim fan I never read the books I've
mixed feelings about the movie do you
pay attention to meme culture are you
two too old I am too old at 36 I'm too
old for meme culture I mean I'm not I
know what memes are but it's not my
thing
do you play many video games not really
too much anymore favorite show in the
arrowverse legends tomorrow it's not
even close some of these got answered
already have you watched not only if I
watched Secret of Kells I own it I love
that favorite series you wish would come
back I don't know cuz I've come to terms
with pretty much all the series that I
like that ended and like I'm at peace
with that kind of would rather they just
stay that way would you like Charlie
Brook would you like Charlie Walker to
write a Doctor Who story I don't know
what like seems like a strong word I'd
be curious sure
have you watched over the garden wall I
have it's awesome how much do you love
ace from Doctor Who I not only go I love
ace the more I'm getting of her the more
I'm loving her orphan black
orphan black yeah I bowed out I think
have four episodes into season four when
it became very clear to me that they
were making this up as they went along I
just couldn't take it anymore and I'd
had issues prior to that ah see I'm
really into Jessica Jones about now good
the good place is forking awesome yes it
is favorite good place couple um I don't
know I mean like it's out of morbid
curiosity I will want to see what
happens if if Eleanor ever tries to make
a move on Thani
let's see are you gonna review watch TV
universe or gravity falls I mean maybe
watch them eventually if if and when I
ever have free time again in my life
review them I don't know what do you
think of the class I'm assuming even the
Doctor Who spin-off I actually haven't
seen it are you a lego nerd not really I
like Lego but I would not call myself
lego nerd
thoughts on the thoughts about the
ballot of scruggs I haven't seen it yet
I want to it's on my to-do list do you
think there are way too many streaming
services not yet there will be soon
some of them will die off we'll see
who's left where would you put twice a
bond of Christmas on your ranking of
Christmas specials on the upper end I
actually like that pretty well and I
don't like a lot of the Christmas
specials do you earn money from YouTube
yes I do
not a living not even close but it's a
supplement has big finished change your
opinion on any of the doctors yes it has
vastly improved my opinion of the Sixth
Doctor
are you a game streamer nope
technology hates me and I do not think
it would work for me what do you think
about that tomorrow people don't really
know anything about it thoughts on the
2005 Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy D
movie I don't love it but my issues with
it don't seem to be the issues a lot of
people have like I hate that version of
Zaphod Beeblebrox so much it's probably
part of the reason I don't really like
Sam Rockwell as an actor ever watch the
British comedy bottom I have not
sexiest Avenger Black Widow like why
would you even have to ask that favorite
x-men film x2 gotten down on any red
dead - I have nothing that would run red
dead - so no have you ever considered
doing a video where you show off all the
cool things on the background of your
set well I mean in my my 10 K Q&A I went
through a lot of this stuff and there
hasn't been that much new added since
then so I don't know
no these are not my daughter's toys at
the background these are all mine she's
got her own toys spread all over the
floor of her room as a seven-year-old is
want to do as series one the best modern
airy series or what is in your V Series
four I still think is the best modern
era have you heard a fashion designer
Katie K from the burlesque scene I
actually haven't
have you watched John Berman and I'm a
celebrity get me out of here no because
I don't really like reality shows
daughter's favorite cartoons at the
moment she really likes she likes
educational TV she really likes PBS she
likes Wild Kratts she likes WordGirl you
know she likes stuff that she comes away
feeling like she learned something do
you think Marvel really need to fix
their animated series I don't know cuz I
haven't seen any of the recent Marvel
animated stuff I never got into like
when they were doing the animated films
like trying to do what DC was doing I
haven't really checked out their series
I've heard decent things but I haven't
gotten to it favorite speedster and then
they list a bunch of DC characters see
the thing is if I were to go speedster I
actually go Quicksilver because I think
the speedsters in DC are super
overpowered do you watch the Orval I
started to and I do want to get back to
it again just time kimmy schmitt
canceled did you know yes I did no I
still have only seen the first season of
it Shh
I'd stay why are u livestreaming during
Doctor Who because this was the only
time I could make it work my original
plan was to do this yesterday but you
know family plans stuff went in such a
way that it just wasn't feasible anymore
it's so weak so weird that I'm so far
behind in looking at these that I'm I'm
now seeing responses to stuff nice I
said like five minutes ago which family
and Game of Thrones is your favorite
Terrell I identify with house Tyrell
very strongly would you like to see the
rani return as opposed to the master not
really the
like the Rani irani I forget how they
pronounce it in the show I don't like I
don't like the character particularly
how do you balance a full-time job in
such frequent upload schedule I don't
sleep
crying Freeman not even sure what that
question means who would win in a fight
Doc Brown versus Willy Wonka depends on
whether or not they have time to plan if
they had time to plan Willy Wonka would
take it but I feel like Doc Brown would
fight dirtier and in the moment thing uh
thoughts on Rick and north favorites he
I'm assuming you mean Rick and Morty I
don't watch it I watched about three
episodes and I get why people like it a
lot I just couldn't connect with these
characters I didn't like any of them I
didn't want to spend more time with any
of these people Space Ghost Coast to
Coast wasn't something I really watched
at the time have you ever met a
subscriber yes I have I have had the
chance to meet you know some people who
knew me through this before they met me
in person which was kind of cool
thoughts on t-series vs. PewDiePie no
thoughts whatsoever with your love of
musicals have you seen the newest stars
born I haven't gotten to it yet I mean
that's that's the kind of movie that was
probably I was gonna be a get to
streaming at eventually let's see how
much classic who have you've watched him
what do you think is the best way to
watch it without spending a lot of money
well I use brick box which is not
available if you're actually in Britain
but I find that to be a completely
reasonable price to pay you know it's a
not very expensive monthly subscription
and you get all the classic dark ooh
plus a whole bunch of other stuff so
that's how I watch it I've I don't think
I've even watch 10% of classic ooh yet
there's a lot of it pinions on Shazam I
like Shazam as a concept and I hope the
movies good didn't know you have a
samurai sword yeah I've got to actually
embarrassingly enough what advice you
have for trans riders in create or if
being trans doesn't matter what advice
do you have for writers or creators I
mean like in terms of being a writer or
creator it's like YouTube or anything
else just do what what fulfills you to
do
whatever you're gonna do whether you're
gonna write were they gonna do YouTube
whether you're gonna do anything else be
sure that what you're doing is something
that you will enjoy even if nobody's
watching cuz there was a very good
chance that nobody will watch nobody
will read and that was something that I
had to kind of get over and like
self-publishing the book and my doing
daily videos on this was not me going oh
I can gain the algorithm I just got into
the habit of doing this stuff and I
loved doing it so be sure you enjoy it
whatever you do be sure you enjoy it
thoughts on the Evil Dead trilogy in the
TV show um I like the movies second
one's the best I saw a little bit of the
TV show but like I'm realizing I'm not
sure I wanted to see more of that much
of an idiot of Ashe like I think one
movie army of Darkness was enough if
you're watching the Maisie Studio Ghibli
films I I have I may at some point rank
Studio Ghibli films I haven't seen the
entire catalog of the studio I've seen
all of Miyazaki except for castle of
Cagliostro it's the only one I've got
left left of that individual reviews
probably not ranking probably eventually
have you watched the expanse
I have not how excited forgot them
series 5 are you very
Gotham doing no-man's land Oh God have
you seen the old British series the
prisoner
I have holy crap that thing's weird and
the remake was terrible there was one
great line from the from the remake or a
dialogue exchange why won't you open
your mind to the possibility that you're
wrong I'm afraid if I open my mind
you'll take it from me we might but
we'll always give it back only good
thing about that remake series god it
was awful favorite Marvel movie at this
point I think still Winter Soldier it's
a it's a tough call though excuse me did
you kind of answer that willing kind of
answer that one
have you watched Batman the Animated
Series I have favorite episode yeah that
is a tough call I don't I'd have to sit
down and think about that have you met
any youtubers no to date I have not I
have yet to meet somebody who I knew in
put somebody in person who I knew
through YouTube first and foremost
[Music]
let's see did that one too Chooch am i
coming close to catching up not really
favorite movie of all time ghostbusters
let's see
thoughts on the second doctor story the
invasion I haven't gotten to that one
yet it's I'll get to it eventually how
did you watch Star Wars the Clone Wars
I haven't again something that I've been
meaning to get to forever but have not
gotten to kind of answer that what do
you think about The Hobbit movies Oh
every one was worse than the last one
and the first one was only okay
any advice for LGBT adults still living
at home with an unsupportive family I
mean you got to do the best that you can
in terms of living in a way that you
don't feel repressed and unfulfilled but
it is really hard for anyone who is
dependent on people who they know aren't
supportive and for as long as that is
the case sometimes you have to suck it
up because there is a reason that LGBT
people make up a disproportionate and
popular amount of the homeless
population because they get thrown out
and unsupported so you you whatever you
have to do to be sure that you are
taking care of sometimes you have to do
that even if it means withholding
yourself which is just an unfortunate
reality paying on the current Star Wars
movies nope not touching that one
favorite mutant the x-men mystique
always every day yeah a couple other
people asked about reviews analysis of
me as I hear studio ghibli yeah at some
point we'll see somebody just said
racism with no context cool awesome
worst movie you've ever seen oh boy I
don't I don't I mean robot monster is
probably the worst movie ever
Sene I'm not sure it's the movie I hate
the most it's just so freakin
incompetent but do you know anything
about The Witcher I don't know if you're
asking me about the books the game is
the upcoming series but it doesn't
matter because I don't know much about
any of them have you seen uu has she Co
I have not I'm still a Buffy fan what
about you having gone back and revisited
some of it yes it's still good which is
a nice is a relief to see what do you
think of article 13 what it means for UK
viewers well I had a video go up
yesterday on article 13 so I won't spend
too much other time here what do you
think of Stargate I never watched the
show I liked the movie
I own the movie scene BBC Sherlock
thoughts oh that last season dived off
the cliff way but like the line
detective is such a good episode but
that first one and then the last episode
oh god it was horrible
um favorite crossover I see haven't been
following the recent crossovers in
comics all your base are belong to us
boy that's reaching back in time oh
thanks Frasier that was a nice one
would you like an animated Doctor Who
not really that mean this person based
I've haven't seen a lot of the animated
doctor stuff it just like yeah not
loving it
do you have Twitter or Instagram yes I
have Twitter as both council of geeks in
here a while then I'm on Instagram has
very wild thoughts on Bruce Campbell
cool food like he's fallen into
basically just playing a caricature
version of himself at this point but he
seems like a cool guy have you seen the
terror nope watch Parks and Rec out
somebody who have been telling me - I've
only seen a couple of episodes like my
partner Liz loves Parks and Rec she
might have to curate like select
episodes for me to see because I tried
starting in season one I'm like not
grabbing me have you seen scrubs nope
favorite character and sensei I've only
seen the first episode of sensei's so
far so I couldn't tell you more
panoramic view of the room no because
it's a mess
so no that's that's not gonna happen you
and your partner are adorable thank you
it's are you gonna review sarah-jane and
Torchwood it's unlikely because I don't
really like either of them enough to
want to revisit them
have you watched fringe I watched a
little bit of season one and just wasn't
grabbed enough to stick with it
Stargate I answered that Sam whoa
Rockwell's my favorite actor are we
enemies yes Oliver I I think now we now
have a blood feud that can only be
settled through a deathmatch so I'll be
in contact we'll set a date are you
gonna watch the Titans show in the DC
app since I refused to pay for that app
nope no I'm not
favorite tenth doctor story and episode
it's well I mean I I'm a I'm a reassess
this at once I finish tenants run you
know with my revisiting with the overdue
Doctor Who reviews but right now it is
signs of librarian force of the Damned
thoughts on Norway it's a country if you
had a TARDIS when and where would you go
I don't know like off planet definitely
I would never go to the past and like I
don't want to screw anything up you
Beast how long you gonna be live for um
gonna have to wrap it up soon actually
I'm gonna what I'm gonna try and do is
I'm gonna try and catch up on the next
few minutes worth of comments but from
the point at which I say this any new
comments that come in after that I
probably won't get to so I'll try and
burn through here martin freeman should
be the fourteenth doctor it wouldn't be
a bad doctor i'd still pull for
Patterson Joseph's favorite quality of
Martha Martha Martha
I didn't look Martha is just smart like
traditionally smart not street smart not
not that sort of clever not to say she
isn't street smart but I like that she
was just straight-up smart
have you watched Death Note I have not
funniest holiday memory from any point
your life I don't know I don't have him
kind of categorized as funny probably
would involve my daughter opening
something thoughts on he-man reboot
series from 2002 I only saw a little
bits of it it seemed fine the best car
game Magic the Gathering or at least it
was last time I played it a decade ago
I other than that I don't know have you
seen Victoria starring the Clara actress
is really good I'm sure it is I have not
seen it
full name full name is Nathaniel Wayne
it's in the end credits of every episode
folks if you ever watched break 7 I have
not I'm familiar with it but I I have
not seen it some more people signing off
I like marvel do you I do I mean if
you're gonna put me against a wall and
say Marvel DC I will go Marvel but
that's not me like DC sucks Monty he's
great it's just a different flavor
you're just a beast so enjoy the money
ok thoughts on the lego movie 2 trailer
I'm not loving that Lucie appears to
have been turned into a damsel in
distress who needs to be rescued but I'm
hoping they subvert that in the same way
they subverted the chosen one narrative
and the first one so hopefully they
don't blow it for the next Doctor in
fact a ginger do you think he she should
be happy with be a happy Irish
incarnation of the guy I think that the
doctor ever becomes ginger that whether
it's a man or woman should look in the
mirror and go I'm ginger I don't like it
and just never bring it up again
you're magic fan and I was back in the
day yep have you heard of okay I can't
even pronounce that and no like broke
like I don't I don't know that his
favorite actor I don't really have one
are you a book reader I was back when I
had longer stretches of free time so
[Music]
what's up with the male-to-female
identifying characters in television and
movies especially kids cartoons that
that is a loaded question that I don't
even know how to begin to answer it's I
am always up for more representation for
LGBTQ because I can speak as someone who
went through my youth seeing nobody who
reflected that part of me and thinking
oh my god I must be weird and that's not
a pleasant thing to grow up with Oh
crying Freeman favorite anime movie oh
okay so that's what that was cool
who are the other two people in the icon
that's Ryan and Paul who were my most
regular collaborators at the time when I
had the the logo made I'm actually gonna
look into getting the logo updated we'll
see thoughts on prank calls hate them I
hate pranks I really do because that I
find I think they're mean because
they're almost always rooted in laughing
at somebody else's pain and I I hate
them good luck with the channel aboard
now oh I'll not be too hurt by that cuz
I'll take it as a as I call back to
Buffy please shout me out ok small lemon
there's your shout out
favorite author Douglas Adams is
Jonathan Creek on Brit box I think so I
haven't watched it but I think so can
you do some sci-fi character impression
that you like I'm I'm not an
impersonator favorite breakfast food
actually don't eat breakfast more often
than not I have a cup of coffee and then
I don't eat until lunch usually have you
seen The Young Ones I have not what do
you think of The Twilight Zone seminoles
show I'm really curious to see what the
revamp under Jordan peels gonna be any
advice for people who are fans of kid
shows who are older but embarrassed
about it and hide it never be ashamed of
something you love I don't believe in
guilty pleasures if it brings you
pleasure there should not be guilt
associated with it provided that
whatever brings you pleasure
it doesn't involve harming or damaging
other people like if it's a piece of
entertainment there's no reason to be
guilty about that they ever talk to who
fandom YouTube chance to bag full I just
I love his self and I love his approach
and I support him on patreon so you can
see stick figure urgent of me over there
sometimes that's always fun
Poseidon Adventure and the reboot I
don't I mean I saw the reboot it's not a
property I really cared too much about
hate comments that have stuck with you I
don't know I still remember the very
first time somebody told me to kill
myself that was way back twenty
seventeen on on a DC movies rant have
you seen Voltron I have not what time of
day is it for you at the time I'm
answering this it is
2:09 which is nine minutes later than I
had intended this to go what advice
would you want to start give to someone
starting their own channel avoid being
seen as a copycat like I said with being
a creator earlier just do what do what
makes you happy and if you start by
imitating somebody else that's fine
provided that you then try and find your
own voice from there I mean you have to
start somewhere would you rather be in
Heaven Sent for eternity or watch
hell-bent for eternity oh my god that's
oh that's just that's not fair to ask me
that do you want Autons to come back and
how I don't really I've got I've never
seen an Auton story that I really cared
all that much about so I don't know have
you watched the Peter crushing Doctor
Who movies I haven't that's on the
docket I will get to those eventually
I'm gonna be wrapping up with the next
few of these the Doctor Who story
Inferno I haven't seen it yet
transformers g'wan are animated haven't
really watched either have you seen
monkey magic I have not a favorite place
besides Amazon to buy geek gear well I
have fallen down at sea holes which is
expensive but there's some good stuff
let's see I have you watched envy of the
world yet I have not thoughts on the
Baker refusing to make a cake for a gay
couple no comment I don't think my
thought should be that hard to suss out
but no comment where'd you get your
stuff on yourselves from most of this as
gifts message retracted watch Beast Wars
no okay I do need to get going
gravity falls no Tokyo ghoul did that
all right I've got this you're the only
Doctor Who youtuber i watch and one of
the nicest lgbtq+ youtubers I've seen
you inspire me you inspire my own
transition I wish you the best quick
question favourite Matt Smith Matt Smith
episode well first of all thank you and
favorite Matt Smith episode I again I I
might reorder this when I get to
revisiting these but right now it's
still the 11th hour but yeah thank you
so I think I think I got to wrap it up
there guys I know I didn't get to
everybody and I'm
I am sorry for that hopefully next time
I do this I'll get the freaking computer
working so I won't have to do it on my
phone and like have my arm outstretched
and kind of bend over cuz now my back's
mad at me so that's that's been lovely
now I have to figure out how I end this
and have it go up as the archived thing
so thanks everybody for joining me like
30,000 subscribers is it's insane
like in the best way it's insane I it's
amazing this is amazing you guys are
amazing I love doing this so yeah I I
try and take my own advice I would keep
doing this even if nobody was watching
because I really do love doing it but
you guys boost that like I think even if
even if I still only have like a
thousand subscribers I probably still
keep doing this I probably wouldn't be
doing daily though because your
enthusiasm and your support really do
give me sort of the extra kick in the
butt and you guys are awesome and don't
plan to stop anytime soon now if I'm
lucky this book this will be archived
for people to watch at a later date if
they want to hopefully I don't
completely screw this up so hope
everybody has great West rest of the
weekend enjoy the new Doctor Who I've
got to run to rehearsal then I got to
come back home watch it
recorder with you edit it um I've got a
full day so have a good one everybody